what's going on guys this is Rob and
everybody gets the centur powers not
even lying so check this out this story
initially opens up with Jessica Jones
what she's doing isn't overly important
she's literally installing a door but
while she's talking to her husband Luke
Cage there's this massive explosion that
goes off not too far away now of course
she responds only to realize that Misty
night and the abant crimes division has
already appeared there kind of a
modern-day reworking of the heroes for
hire with some upgrade if we're being
honest with ourselves the long and short
of this is that between these two who
have been kind of on again off again
allies in different circumstances they
kind of start going through and one
talking to the different people who had
seen this explosion and two trying to
figure out what caused it and where
people are saying things like our
apartment got hit by laser beams and so
on and so forth there aren't really any
clearcut answers as to what's happening
and in the world of superheroes it could
be basically anything but one of the
things that ends up going on here is
that in this conversation between Misty
night in Jessica Jones one of the things
that Jessica Jones says is that a family
perished from the explosion in Columbus
but 18-year-old Ryan topper is yet to be
accounted for now one of the things that
I want you guys to do over the course of
this video is I don't want you guys to
look at this from the perspective of a
Marvel comic I want you to look at it
from the perspective of Heroes if you
ever saw that show and the hunt for
Gabriel Syer right like because this is
basically that right that's effectively
what this story is and so one of the
things that goes on here is you actually
switched to earlier that day with a girl
by the name of mallerie gives and this
girl is of course somebody who has
cerebral paly so she can't walk but she
does have kind of a really cool social
media brand where she got like really
into calligraphy when she was younger
and so the result is that she just kind
of like records herself doing
calligraphy I don't know if that's a
thing if it is it sounds dope and I'll
probably check out a couple videos about
it but in the mid of her doing this and
basically recording everything she gets
a glimpse of the moment when the century
fights the Hulk in World War Hulk and
then suddenly she lights up right like
these Powers just seemingly come out of
nowhere she goes flying through the
apartment building like a bat out of
hell lands in the laundry bin but when
she's in there everything's frozen now
one of the things that I also want to
establish here is that the centures
powers historically in Marvel Comics
have been very ambiguous sometimes he
can alter reality sometimes he can't
sometimes he can fly faster than the
speed of light sometimes he can fly as
fast as the speed of sound he was very
much a character whose abilities were
contextual to the story that was being
written something people absolutely
hated about the century right people
just despised that element to his
character and so one of the things
you're going to notice over the course
of this is Marvel is actually
consolidating down the nature of the
Century's powers and establishing
exactly what it is that he can do
through each one of these people who are
going to pick up his powers and so one
of the things things that establishes
here is that the century effectively had
the ability to freeze time either that
or she's moving so incredibly fast that
everything seems like it's frozen but
it's most likely the former right the
fact that she was able to effectively
freeze time and the reason why is
because when that happens she ends up
like snatching these people up and just
like racing them out of the building
when she starts to realize that the
whole building is about to collapse and
so when they reemerge they don't really
know what's going on right I mean it's
like that scene from what was it X-Men
Days of Future pass when Quicksilver was
racing everybody out of the building
probably one of the greatest scenes ever
in the history of a comic book movie but
then like once everybody's basically
rescued Maller is just kind of out there
just looking at stuff and that's it once
she races off everything seemingly snaps
back to normal which is why nobody
looked up and said like who's that girl
that's flying away with a streak of
yellow behind her right so a pretty neat
way to kind of allow this scene to
unfold without anybody having any
indication of what went on now one of
the things that happens is that the
belongings of mallerie are basically
gathered together by Misty Knight and
Jessica Jones and the reason for this is
because one of mallerie's friends had
been in the apartment building when
everything went sideways and she had
actually told Misty and Jessica there's
a girl named mallerie who is handicap in
that building you need to get her out
and so once they have all these
belongings brought together using of
course the advanced technology at their
disposal Misty Knight's able to pull
information from the cell phone she sees
the recording and then realizes okay
this is the second person to gain the
powers of the century right that like
topper has them now mallerie has them
and so at that point you switch over to
another guy who's actually a door Dash
driver right this guy's name is farad
and this guy once he drops off the door
Dash because of how he looks this guy's
like okay so like you're a mutant
clearly and then doesn't give him a tip
which is just kind of a dick thing to do
right like just that's pretty crappy but
one of the things this guy says is he
doesn't really have any special powers
that he simply just looks different now
that's an important thing to understand
and the reason why is because after his
delivery is done and his day basically
over he goes to the gym to hang out with
his friends play some basketball that
kind of thing but what ends up happening
is that in that moment he glimpses the
century ripping Carnage in half now
unlike the century fighting the Hulk
which is just well known in the Marvel
Community this one needs a little more
explanation so in Marvel Comics the
century has kind of like two Origin
stories if you want to call it that
there's the original Paul Jenkins and
Jay Lee the century story which was
initially supposed to be a one-off right
like that was it like it was done he was
never going to be seen or heard from
again but because of how popular he was
Brian Michael Bendis when he started New
Avengers the first and second story arcs
feature the century the first story arc
is where this one comes from when the
century basically escapes from the raft
grabs the century flies him into space
and tears him in half it's one of the
most iconic scenes from the century and
we actually covered it if you're
interested in in seeing that story I'll
have a link to it here at the end of the
video but the thing about this is that
once this happens much like what we saw
with mallerie suddenly these Powers
manifest but as opposed to it being like
this kind of massive explosion that
basically levels an entire building it's
enough to do damage in the general area
but then seemingly this guy develops
telepathy he starts hearing the thoughts
of the people around him not only that
he develops super speed now super speed
seems to be kind of the standard thing
right mallerie obviously had it this guy
clearly has it and he just races super
fast and ends up running to a park in
order to kind of calm himself down at
that point he's met by topper and this
is why I say Heroes and Syler because as
those of you guys who watch the heroes
show know in like the first season Syler
was the bad guy and he was going around
killing people that had powers and
taking their abilities the worst thing
they did was reveal him that was a
terrible decision he should have just
stay this like clandestine mysterious
guy for at least another season but be
that as it may as the two of them having
a conversation this guy Ryan topper
right he like literally introduces
himself that kind of thing and kind of
explains what's going on to farad and
simply saying like most likely what
happened here is you had a glimpse of
the Century's memories and then gained
his powers and that in doing so you now
have a portion of what he's capable of
now here's one of the other things that
I want to explain here because by this
point you guys are probably kind of like
okay but like what's going on with the
century Robert Reynolds the century died
during King and black right he kind of
came back as like a weird vessel
possessed by demons type thing in the
strange series with Clea but that
doesn't matter the important thing is
that Robert Reynolds is dead and has
been dead and in fact during the
valkyrie's tie-in for King in Black he
moved on to the afterlife right so
Marvel officially killed him off and so
the result of this is that his power
still kind of remains for whatever
reason that makes sense to nobody but
Marvel and different people are
inheriting his abilities that's
effectively what's going on here and so
the results of this is that as they're
having this conversation literally farod
initially thinks that like Thor is the
most powerful Avenger of course Ryan
corrects him and says no no no it's the
century and when he asks him what powers
did you get his response at least far's
response is I don't know like running
really fast but also telepathy and so
the response of Ryan is it doesn't
really matter I want them all and he
immediately attacks this guy right again
just a huge reference to silent and so
the fight between the two of them is
actually pretty interesting for a couple
reasons one because what we're
established here at least what we're
given here is that Ryan topper has a
much better understanding of these
Powers than farad does which makes sense
because seemingly Toppers had them for
probably a couple weeks or so right
farad just got them like 15 minutes ago
right if that right so it's just one of
those things where like just using them
for a longer period of time but even
then right like what you end up getting
is suddenly almost like this uh
ingrained memory where like farad just
inherently knows how to use these
abilities on some level now we could
could argue this to just the nature of
the plot or we could say it's tied into
the centuries memories it's one of the
things that we don't fully know and
honestly it doesn't really matter all
that much right like topper gets hit
with heat vision which is kind of a cool
thing to see and then like farad refers
to topper as a psychopath because topper
simply wants to take out everybody that
has the centu powers and absorb them
into himself now the other thing here is
that topper also much like most every
normal human out there seems to just
have a vendetta against farad because
like he's a mutant right it is kind of
cool that they're throwing that in there
especially given everything going on
with fall of X not overly important but
it is good to see this kind of being
thrown in a little bit given the context
of everything that's going on in Marvel
Comics but one of the things that
happens is that as the two of them are
fighting farad doesn't have any
technique this guy's not a fighter right
and he's certainly not like the century
and he's not like wolver rain or anybody
like that although the century was
really more a brawler than like a more
skilled fighter or anything along those
lines but topper literally asked ra the
question like didn't your dad teach you
how to fight because he taught me how to
fight and he rips his arm off right and
then just like absorbs his power and
like that's it right he's just like one
less rival I hope the others will be as
easy to find and that's it and so what
you end up doing is jumping to the moon
and you basically have mallerie who's
just been on the moon this entire time
kind of saying like this is the only way
nobody gets hurt but in the background
you seemingly have three other people
who have also gained the powers of the
century and wouldn't you know it guys
what a
coincidence one of these guys looks like
Stephen Yun the exact guy who's going to
be playing the century in the
Thunderbolts film my goodness what a
coincidence man if only there was a way
to know exactly how this story is going
to end with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an and Marvel
stop being lazy I will catch you all
later peace